Adam Plantenburg: Nice Owen Garitty: Nice
Adam: You want me to smile at the camera?
Stoic?
Just chill?
Owen: Are you going to do the [makes a serious
face] Hold on, should I have my tea?
Probably.
I’ve been sitting here for 15 minutes trying
to figure out how to intro this video, so…here’s
the intro to the video…I’m Owen with FPW
Media.
Adam: I’m Adam from FPW Media.
Owen: And we’re here to talk about a video
we recently did called I AM APEX for Timber
Products Company specifically for their Ampine
division, specifically when they came to us
about launching their new product Apex, which
is a composite panel product.
We really worked hard and thought about how
can we make that visually interesting?
We decided to have the story of the production
of one of these panels be told from the perspective
of the panel.
So we shot the whole project on a Red camera.
We shot on a Red Epic W and a Red Epic Dragon.
What is really interesting is that the mills
are really, really, really dark.
Like…you can attest to this…
Adam Plantenburg: Insanely dark!
Owen Garitty: Insanely dark.
So we shot most of it at 3200 ISO (I think)?
Adam: Yeah.
Owen: Is that right?
That seems about right, yeah.
Which is nuts.
And I mean, it looked fantastic.
We shot it mostly on Canon still glass L series
lenses, with a cinema lens here and there
thrown in.
I’d say it’s an artistic decision but
it was also driven by necessity but it was
really awesome how it worked out in that the
lighting…we knew that going in lighting
was going to be a huge problem.
We’ve shot in a lot of mills before so we
decided to embrace that lighting was going
to be a challenge and actually psychically
show a lot of our lights in the shots because
in the mills there are all sorts of different
lights that are different bulbs, different
color temperatures, and we knew that we were
going to have no control over that.
Adam: Yeah, because a lot of the times it
looked like what we’re shooting is a spot
that needs to be examined anyways, so it could
be a light that’s spotted on there for a
specific reason.
Owen: Right.
So probably one of the hardest shots (I would
say from a safety perspective and just like
a planning perspective) was our shots in the
furnished room where the dust comes in and
the furnish comes into be made into the board
and the graded footage (you can’t really
tell) but there it was so dusty that when
they were moving, it was probably like a whiteout
almost.
I mean, Adam was basically…and I don’t
actually know, were you behind me?
Adam: Yeah, so I had one hand on your safety
vest just kind of pulling you around, making
sure that you didn’t run into anything.
That if the loader was coming at you, we weren’t
too close and then at one point your safety
glasses fell off and you must have just been
filming blind essentially.
Owen: I basically was.
I mean it was like I kind of knew where I
could see where the loader was and I could
kind of see the camera, but I was just imaging
the framing because I couldn’t even see
the screen because the screen got completely
covered over with dust at one point, but it
turned out really well.
Adam: And as soon as the take was over it
would be us running out putting the camera
on the stand and then just blowing it off
like crazy…
Owen: Oh, no!
Where did Adam go?
I’m sitting here with Jake, our senior editor
at FPW Media to talk about the post-production
process on I AM APEX.
Jake do you want to kind of take us through
our last product shot where we get back into
the narrative?
Jake Sullivan: Yeah, and sometimes that’s
great because that one was actually really
easy.
That was kind of borne out of the camera movement
and then all I had to do was really dip to
black there and pay close attention to where
we were making the actual cut in both of those.
Owen: And we kind of threw you a curveball
in that one a little bit because that part
of the project wasn’t shot until almost
the whole edit was done, I would say so you
had this kind of gaping hole for most of the
edit where those product shots were supposedly
going to go.
Jake: And those were also kind of fun because
we had a lot of visual effects to cover things
that we couldn’t get in camera.
Owen: So you added more fire, what else?
Jake: More fire in the studio is kind of hard
to not light things on fire [laughs]…so…
Owen: Right.
And then on the moisture scene, you added
a couple layers in front?
Or how did that work?
Jake: I added a couple layers of smoke in
front and then I masked out the actual piece
and added a couple behind it to give that
sense of depth that it has.
Owen: All and all, I think it is one of the
projects that I’m most proud of.
We had a blast filming it and if anybody has
any questions about the production or the
gear we used or anything like that, please
reach out to us and make sure to watch the
video in full.
Thanks for watching!